Well, let's see. The way I would approach this problem is by first, thinking about what we have.
What we have is potential energy and I'm going to call that the initial potential energy.
Since what we're going to need will require both some potential energy final and some kinetic energy.
Now hopefully, what we have is greater than what we need because
we're going to lose some energy when we go over this area with friction.
If I think about this in terms of energy, the final energy would just be
whatever my energy is minus how much I lose here.
The amount of energy I lose, well, that would just be the work done by friction.
How much energy is lost? Well, I can rewrite this equation like this. Okay, fair enough.
We need the initial energy and the final energy, and then we can convert that to some sort of work
and we should know the maximum force, not bad.
Well, the initial energy that's just the potential energy.
The final energy is our final potential energy and remember this is now a height of 2R,
so this is an expression for my energy lost.
I can plug in my known values from up here and I find energy lost is equals to 40,000 joules,
and how is that energy getting lost? Well, friction is doing work.
Let's take a look at a force diagram for the car.
We've got our standard weight in normal force and since the car is moving to the right,
friction is point to the left and note that this is exactly parallel going the opposite direction
as the direction of motion, so we can use our equation, work equals F parallel times distance.
And I get an answer of 2000 N. Now you may have also called this negative.
I was being a little sloppy here with what I should call negative and positive.
We accepted that ± 2000 N for the answer.